this video is sponsored by squarespace a
huge thank you to those guys for helping
me to make more of the content i love
to get the very most of your training
you need to know why you're training
that way you know what to prioritize and
what not to fret about the problem is
that a lot of us never do this sort of
soul-searching and as such we end up
falling into training programs and diet
plans that aren't necessarily the most
conducive to where we actually want to
be as an example a lot of people end up
following training programs that aim to
get them to sub 10 body fat this is
something that
a lot of people are obsessed with and
yet i think it actually has very little
benefit and in fact it might be doing
more harm
than good in the long run
[Music]
in fact i'd be willing to bet that 99.9
percent of people watching this video
unless fitness is your profession in
some way do not need sub 10 body fat and
if that's your focus right now then you
could be using your energy a lot more
effectively elsewhere
let's start with the obvious i am not at
sub 10 body fat i'd say i'm somewhere
around 15 this fluctuates maybe goes
down to about 13 and all the way up to
16 17
19 i don't know i can't tell you my
exact body fat percentage because uh i
don't care and i know i'm not going to
win any bodybuilding competitions
anytime soon however i would certainly
say that my abs are visible and that's
evidence that you can have visible abs
at those higher body fat percentages
of course not everyone is going to have
abs at 15 body fat the reason that i do
is because i train and i train quite
hard some people will tell you that the
only thing that matters when it comes to
visible abs is having a low body fat
percentage but this isn't true and i can
demonstrate it look
here's me with my abs fully relaxed
here's me with my abs contracted
as you can see it makes quite a big
difference
that's because the abs are protruding
more and because i'm pulling in my gut
using my transverse abdomini so simply
by having stronger and bigger abdominal
muscles core muscles you can make your
core look stronger even poking through
that ample layer of additional fat
and using exercises also target the
obliques is also really beneficial
because that'll give you that extra nice
detail on the sides that makes your core
look more shredded even if it isn't
but you know what that's not actually my
point i have a huge amount of respect
for people that manage to get to below
10 body fat and look super shredded
would i like to have 6 body fat probably
i just don't think it's necessarily
worth it and i don't even think you
necessarily need to worry about visible
abs especially if fitness isn't your job
fitness is my job and i can't be
bothered that low body fat can rob you
of your energy
it can ruin your mood and just the fact
you're eating so little means you'll
have less energy for your workouts as
well
of course for endurance events it's
going to mean you have
less reserves to dig into some people
are really into their calisthenics like
to try and drop their body weight of
course because then they're lifting less
and they can do more impressive moves
more easily that's cool but again in all
honesty a few percent body fat is going
to make a huge difference to your weight
of course it still makes a lot of sense
to lose that weight but again unless
you're someone who's really keen on
learning the planche you don't need to
worry about it
it's actually raining pretty heavily now
better get into the car again
now let's take a moment to talk about
today's sponsor squarespace squarespace
is a powerful online platform for
developing modern attractive and
professional websites it gives you all
the tools to easily create your own site
with zero coding necessary this way you
can turn your passion into a business
squarespace makes this easy with a
number of features start generating
revenue through gated members only
content manage members send email
communications and leverage audience
insights all from a single easy to use
platform you also get a fully integrated
commenting system with support for
threaded comments replies and likes
share content categorize posts schedule
publishing and more with a complete
suite of blogging tools plus display
social media posts and push social media
content directly to your website there
are also powerful ecommerce capabilities
that can be upgraded further with
additional extensions these help with
managing inventory promoting products
streamlining bookkeeping reconciling and
filing sales tax shipping globally and
more go to squarespace.com for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
bioneer viewers can get 10 off the
purchase of their first website or
domain by going to squarespace.com
forward slash bioneer today
and now on with the show
having a little bit of extra weight also
means you've got a bit of extra weight
to put behind you whether that's for
throwing a punch throwing a ball
throwing a person or even pushing
certain weights in particular exercises
anyways who's even really gonna see your
abs you've got your top on most of the
time did you know that most gyms won't
let you take your top off whilst you're
training i know right so it makes sense
if you're worried about your looks to
train things that people are actually
going to see like your biceps and your
neck
if you're trying to get to sub 10 body
fat because you want to impress members
of the opposite sex then you can
probably rest assured that that's not
the problem
it's your personality
so a lot of productivity gurus always
tell us how every single decision has a
cost they talk about decision fatigue
the very fact that you're making
decisions is tiring for the brain and
this is a limited finite source that you
can deplete thus ruining your ability to
make good decisions later on in the day
this is famously why steve jobs would
apparently wear the exact same outfit
every single day and willpower is even
more difficult studies show that as the
day goes on we find it harder and harder
to not indulge in the things that we
know we shouldn't but in the same breath
those same gurus are like oh also
measure every single thing you eat and
avoid eating anything that you shouldn't
because you're going to be measuring
every single thing you eat working out
how many calories are in there you're
going to be turning down food left and
right and eating things that you just
don't find exciting a lot of the time
and when you do you're gonna be having
really small portion sizes if we're
looking at becoming healthier and fitter
then is this really a healthy
relationship to have with your food and
is it really a sustainable one if you
have a big weight problem and you're
trying to lose weight then counting
calories is a very effective method and
it can work great for a lot of people
but if you have just like slightly less
visible abs than you would like or
you're just not quite as in shape as you
would like then
this really is an extreme option and
especially if you're planning to do this
you know forever what is important is
that you're getting plenty of nutrients
and that you're getting enough energy to
fuel your workouts and to feel great and
to sleep better and all these things are
much easier to do when you eat a little
bit more most people can get by
perfectly fine by just eating a little
bit intuitively you know if you're
eating too much and you know that if you
want to lose weight you can just cut out
some of what's in your diet yes this
might not be the fastest way to get to
sub 10
but that's the whole point you don't
need to just eat sensibly eat more
natural than processed foods and try and
lower your caloric intake if you notice
yourself getting a bit softer maybe try
and intermittent fast every once in a
while it can be very healthy for you but
don't slave away and eat only dull foods
just for the sake of being able to say
you have 10
body fat because i don't think that's
healthy and it's not going to make you
feel great
so i'm not saying that there's never any
point to getting ripped not at all i'm
just saying that we mustn't conflate
visible abs with fitness having a lower
body fat percentage beyond a certain
point does not necessarily make you
fitter than the next person it's really
a distraction to me fitness is about
moving and feeling better visible abs
won't improve your performance in any
meaningful way they won't make you feel
better in yourself and the process may
even make you feel much worse
the same could be said for many other
things that we equate with fitness
getting a slightly bigger bicep adding a
few kilograms to a lift you're already
supremely good at
or working extremely hard for a
calisthenic skill when there are other
more pressing aspects of your fitness
missing
again these are all worthwhile in the
right context but they are not the same
thing as being fit
don't feel any pressure to get ripped
and before you go down that path take a
moment to ensure that's really what you
want and that it's going to be worth the
effort
so thanks so much for watching this one
guys i hope you found it useful and
interesting if you did then please
consider leaving a like and sharing it
around that helps me out immensely do
you care about abs and lower than 10
body fat let me know in the comments
down below if you enjoy this kind of
training that's more focused on
performance and feeling great although
great physique does tend to be a welcome
side effect then you might enjoy my
ebook and training program super
functional training there's a discount
on that right now and there's some
interesting news coming about that in
the coming days i'll put a link in the
description down below
either way thank you so much for
watching this one
and bye for now